Hello, everybody. Welcome to another Zoom call.
There's a couple of questions in that.
I'm only done. So start typing your questions if you have some.
Okay, let's jump into it.
One of my local practitioners told me about a Dutch test from Physicians Lab.
It doesn't have the organic acid.
Old test, like the other brand, the president, analytically.
Does that matter? Do I need an old test?
Have you heard of this lab before?
So there are several that have the technology to do a Dutch test.
So you can get it anywhere you want to get it.
And you go, I don't recommend people.
So there's a Dutch complete and there's a Dutch plus from precision labs.
I can't remember which one of them has the old test.
It does not have the old test.
I always recommend people get the less expensive one because you don't need the old test.
But the one thing I do like about the precision analytical one is that it also comes with a cortisol test, which I think that has value with cancer patients.
So if the, if the one from Physicians Lab has that, then by all means go for it.
Or if it's, if it's far less expensive than by all means go for that.
The only thing that I would say is that if you're going to get a Dutch test done or any lab test done, there is wisdom in getting it from the same law.
And then compare results.
So it's using different equipment and it's just best to get it done at the same lab.
And I've shared that about same thing about getting it done or MRI or a PET scan.
It's always if you're going to hearing apples to apples, you're better off getting it done.
At the same lab, getting an ultrasound, a breast ultrasound done is best to go to the exact same technique.
It's not always possible, but certainly getting it done at the same lab is usually with a possibility.
And so if you, if the person asking this question has never done a Dutch test before and they're just getting it done, well, you can start with using a different lab.
If you have some, you know, desire to do so, whether it's less expensive or whatever.
Your thought process says, well, as far as have I heard of that lab that I couldn't recall if I saw their logo, maybe at a very specific.
I'm not going to recall.
I would just continue if you're going to use that lab and continue to use that lab, but follow ups to remember this one test is not an adult deal.
You have to compare it with other sites and symptoms, subjective and objective things that are going on as well as comparative tests, parents of labs over and over I've seen people.
In a CBC, you know, clean metabolic panel done and there's abnormal findings in the practitioner never tells them to do another one.
Let me have time to never even address the abnormal findings, but if they try it, some sort of treatment programs try to adjust, try to address those available findings and then you'd ever read better.
Whether your treatment program work to address those abnormal findings, how do you know?
You're doing the right thing.
So that would be like this re-basher.
How long do I continue to take the leopathic drops for it after my PET scan or CT scanner?
Same question. How do I take the MRI?
You had a lid of drops after my MRI.
It's untressed.
I would say that you continue to take, so the phobia, phobia path for radiation.
I would say you go through the whole bottle.
You just might as well use it up.
So it's going to take probably six months to go through the bottle.
It's hard to get rid of radiation, toxicity.
So you know, I would keep taking it.
I think that would be your best friend.
Same thing with Catalidium from the MRI.
Even if you don't have Catalidium sensitivity, it can build up with your brain.
So I'm going longer.
You can take that the better.
So I'd say just both you release the whole bomb.
And if you go and do it on your scan.
You would again, so I'd keep taking it.
Pretty simple to take a hold of your hand.
That's really the downsides.
I've been feeling like I need to add juiced or blending to my diet to get more vegetables down.
When I got my genetics tested done, I learned that my body does not.
Do a good job converting beta-carotene to vitamin A.
Does this mean I should limit carrots in my juicing and blending?
No, it doesn't.
Matter of fact, it would mean that.
So the conversion process, when you have that, I think it's a BCMO gene defect.
You have a more difficult time with vitamin A.
And converting beta-carotene to your active role of vitamin A.
So one line of thought is that you should take more of beta-carotene because then you'll end up with more converted usable vitamin A in your body.
So I would kind of hold to that.
So I don't think you need to limit carrots in your juicing and blending.
The thing I would say about juiced and blending is that.
You have to have a healthy gut to do that because if you have a leaky gut issue.
Juiced and blending is raw so that, you know, we talked about this before.
And I have blog posts on this too that you know these.
Practitioners that say you have cancer, everything you should go to a raw food diet.
That is just not true.
A raw food diet can be really hard on your gut, even if it's juiced or blended.
You're just pretty digested it.
It's still hard to absorb those things.
It can still be irritated to the gut wall.
So if you have a lot of intestinal permeability, aka a leaky gut syndrome.
A raw food diet can be hard on it.
You know, the adage of the cochlear vegetables, you destroy all the nutrients in your vegetables.
That's only a partial truth.
The gaps diet which we used in the past for.
All our ADD, ADHD, fibrobalgia, autoimmune patients.
Was beneficial and it worked.
And the reason why it works is because.
You're breaking down the cell.
A wall of the the of the plants so that they're more easily digested.
So it does take a lot of pressure.
So you're getting more the nutrients out of them.
So that you are able to absorb the nutrients, especially if you're cooking in a soup.
So if you're making soup.
So we used to give these people out of gaps diet or.
We're eating bone broths and what's the benefit of bone broths.
You don't want to do that necessarily cancer patient.
Well, they're eating bone broth to have high end of glutamate.
So it helps heal the gut.
Lighting.
And then you're getting them just eating soups.
So they're vegetables in the bone broth.
And now you're getting nutrients to help heal the gut in your in a raw form.
It's too irritated on the gut.
So these people that have leaky gut issues of intestinal permeability issues.
Already inflammatory issues.
You it can be hard on your gut to have raw foods.
You're much more susceptible to the protein in raw foods as well to develop antibodies against.
So remember, if you have a leaky gut.
You have a greater chance of developing antibodies to different peptides.
AKA proteins in different foods.
That's why we advocate towards using Syrex 10 panophen.
Because it tests for many of these common food sensitivities in both cooked and raw foods.
Because the protein is different in whether it's cooked or it's raw.
So.
Something to consider at least with that.
Do you have any thoughts or info thoughts about Lea trail making them be 17 apricot seeds.
They can about him right now.
That's what I'm doing.
Yep.
Just kidding.
So of course, I've lots of thoughts about it and I write about it in my book.
Post about it.
So these 17 is a very potent.
Oxidized agent for cancer.
So.
In my latest blog post about heartic ed oxidative stress to kill cancer.
I talk about core different nutrients.
Those dependently affected cancer cells.
Can't go excited to see some idea.
What else do I write about?
Invited me.
Bell to talk to treat us.
And.
And Bella told it.
Well, Lea trail.
I don't have to be those dependent for Lea trail to be an oxidized agent.
That's how these 17 works.
It's an oxidized agent.
So.
You know, we always think oxidized agents are bad.
Well, it's all about balance and oxidizing agents are fairly beneficial.
Your body makes.
Oxidized agents.
It makes reactive oxygen and reaction nitrogen species.
In the presence of stress, whether it's microbial stress waiting that we have an infection or emotional stress you develop.
More reactive oxygen species.
For the purpose of killing microbes has other functions in your body too.
And you keep that in balance with your antioxidant system intercellular.
Well, these 17 is an oxidized agent similar to chemo is an oxidized agent.
Similar to those at a different nutrients that are in dormal doses, antioxidants.
So they can be very great killers of cancer.
So read that post.
If you really feel led to use B 17, I think the best product on the market is the apricot power brand we have it at our store.
I just go, you know, go slow on it.
It's not ghost dependent upon its function.
It is an oxidized agent.
People to add 100 milligrams a day.
But the dose dependency on being 17 is based upon its effective killing.
How fast the cancer is growing.
So cancer is growing quickly.
Then you use a higher dose.
That's when we slightly didn't use a lesser dose or use it.
From a perspective of just preventative, that could actually be done too.
So most of the nutrients like B 17, other oxidized agents, they tend not to damage healthy cells, unless you take your high doses.
So high doses.
So these 70 comes in 100 milligram capsules and 500 milligram capsules.
So high dosage partly depends on the weight of the person, but for a person who's a hundred and 50 pounds.
That's three, 500 milligram capsules.
If you had a milligram capsules, it would be.
And then again, how bad the cancer isn't how long you're using the stoves would be a pretty normal dose to take.
More of a long term dose.
It even do be 17 intravenous and a much higher dose.
But of course that's based out.
You're not doing it every day.
And you're not doing it.
You don't want to turn.
So you're just trying to not know the cancer quickly.
Next question. Is there such a thing as gentle radiation?
What will happen to my arm if I did radiation?
I know you recommended for bone only.
So technically from a physics standpoint, the sunshine is gentle radiation.
If you're defining gentle radiation as something that's not going to cause damage to tissue,
then there's no such thing as gentle radiation for treatment of kids.
So if you're talking of you have to use a high enough rad dose of radiation to kill a cell.
So it's there's no such thing as gentle radiation for treatment, fidelity of cancer.
You are only allowed to get so much of a rad dose of radiation.
That's where you hear people that did radiation.
Not the times that now the doctor said we can't give you any more radiation.
You're passed your rad dose.
Because there is a different rules in the radiation treatment perspective that you can only get so much radiation.
Because it's just going to be too many other damaging effects of the radiation.
The reason why I am more of a fan of radiation to bone than I am to soft tissue is that you can get more specific to a spot in the bone.
It's harder to get specific to a spot in soft tissue.
And you can see quick results with it.
You really think of it. You really think of it if there was magically no ill effects of the radiation.
It's a phenomenal treatment to kill cancer.
It was pinpointed that cancer with this lethal dose and you're destroying the cancer.
Well, the problem is you have to get, you know, it goes, you know, in a vector.
And it continues, you know, it bounces around the room.
Because the room is lead line and it's bouncing around the room and it absorbs it to the lead wall and absorbed it to tissue.
So your tissue will absorb it.
So when they're trying to pinpoint it, they run these vector beings at different angles so that they're all going to converge in one spot and therefore it's going to be a lethal dose at that spot.
That all these beings converge and it's not going to be a lethal dose at the spots that those beings go through your tissues and don't converge.
It's the best that can be done, but it's still not perfect, even though you don't have a lethal dose meaning it's not killing all the cells that it's going through.
It's still, it's still damaging those cells.
So damaged cells can produce cancerous tissue.
It's certainly not unheard of.
You're going to have people listening to this call right now that have received breast cancer treatment, whether it be a lumpectomy or a mastectomy.
It did radiation just as exactly how the oncologist prescribed it now.
They have these cancerous oils growing on one side of their chest wall because of the radiation treatment.
I've seen this time and time again.
So it may be not like tissue radiation because of that.
So I do think you have to use wisdom and I do think there's a place for it like radiating bowl with what the person is having excruciating both.
So I think there's a place where how long do I wait to recheck after my pet scan and what scan do I request.
I doubt my insurance company will pay for it on a pet scan, especially since they probably only did this one because it was six months.
I check up after my double mastectomy and I did quite conventional treatment and afterwards.
My oncologist still has not called about my results.
So well if pet scans did it have any ill effects, no radiation, no markers, no glucose use, et cetera, it'd be a wonderful world.
And we could, if they were free, we could just do it every week and we could see the progress objectively our treatment for our close.
However, we don't live in a perfect world and none of those things are true.
So how long are you going to wait to do that in a pet scan?
Well, that is depending upon a couple of things whether the oncologist would do it, whether your insurance will pay for it.
Even if you are a wealthy woman, you could, I'd say I was going to pay for it on a clock of myself.
The oncologist might be stubborn enough, he'd been ordering for you.
So then you have to deal with the ill effects is the rows of doughy by progress.
More important than the hills of radiating my body and causing damage to my body.
Pet scan is prevalent, I don't remember, hitting like 50 chest checks, right?
So you can't just poo poo that and say that that isn't all be fine.
If you get enough pet scans and CT scans and MRIs, you can have ill effects and that can be cancer-causing in itself.
So you got to weigh all these things out.
And what's important for you to know are there other objective tests that you can do that can give you enough data for you to be confident that you're moving in the right direction.
I don't know, everybody has to make that decision for themselves.
I for one don't want to get any sea cheese or anything so.
Okay, thank you so much, Mark.
Yeah, so there's pros and cons to different labs, there's pros and cons to different testing.
And just because we do something that is quote, quote, quote, standard according to practice and standards of care, it doesn't mean it's a perfect.
So talk to somebody today that did a, you know, MRI and, you know, then do another test and MRI was just wrong.
And it says so, it's just not, nothing's perfect.
So, you just got to weigh that out.
Whole body MRIs without contrast are available to some medical or those any good.
I think you're talking about the pre-dubo test.
If you are, I think they're good. That's what I had done.
So I did the pre-dubo.
If you look up pre-dubo, I think it's PR and, you know, there's clinics all around the country.
Now, I think there's about a dozen clinics in the United States that you could do that.
Again, the negative of that is that insurance doesn't cover that.
You can schedule it.
Yeah, I don't even know if we need a doctor, you know, request.
You could just schedule another website.
But I think they're worth putting about $500.
But she's got to weigh out whether that's what you want to do.
I think they're good tests.
We didn't have one person about a year ago on his in-call.
Did it and she, she didn't like it.
I can't remember who did it.
I can't remember if we didn't like it and write it and like it.
I did it and I was very happy with the results.
I think they formulated.
I was getting much better at that time.
Feeling way better.
And it showed.
I mean, I just had a couple of reasons in my liver.
That's a time and.
It's not really well.
So.
This is 650 cash.
So that's probably not the pre-dubo broadcast then.
So I don't know.
So the benefit, you know, the whole body MRI without contrast.
You're going to be missing some things too.
So.
Now, I'm not sure about.
Not doing it with contrast.
Again, you know, any any test you do is going to have pros and cons.
So again, nothing is going to be perfect.
Imagine they'd be able to see everything that's going on inside your body.
It's all right.
We will call it a night.
Thanks for jumping on.
Now.
I'm sure you get your questions in.
So you get an answer.
Go that.
I'm praying for all you guys.
Keep up the good fight.
Go that.
We're on your side.
I'm on your side.
All right.
Love you all.
Bye-bye.